hey guys I'm Ryan right let's be crazy
I'm Dan fatter we're gonna watch the
trailer for one of my favorite
television shows of all time legend of
korra the book for balance trailer
excellence now if I'm correct this
season is supposed to be its most
intense season ever yes yes this is
supposed to be true well yeah I heard
they're taking it to the next level cuz
I follow the show so well I know the
main characters I know the I know the
direction the show is going in right now
oh I understand the dialogue when it's
being spoken it's a it's one hell of a
fantastic series you know what I
appreciate is I was just going over this
with somebody yesterday um it got so
dark was that I had no I [ __ ]
somebody with somebody who will not be
named right now it is so dark that it
actually is not airing on the
Nickelodeon channel anymore it's only
online which is awesome because I think
it gives them more freedom and I knew
that I thought that's the funny thing is
I knew then and knew that man this check
of a thousand lies is pretty enticing is
this gonna Kansas get bounce on me I
just kept bouncing no don't let this
check bounced on me no no Jude trust me
I know exactly it's you guys are acting
like the only time I heard a Legend of
Korra was when it was requested I knew
about her before we we know we know but
in all seriousness guys I am like I love
the entirety of the avatar series from
the start to now and it is so good that
James Cameron movie is really good I
know what you're talking about I just
started watching and it's awesome cuz I
watched the first first like series and
that was freaking awesome so now I have
a lot of catching up to do I'm not gonna
make it in time for this but I will push
forward triumphantly that's so great I'm
like gonna be ready for the premiere I'm
gonna be sitting on my computer just
like ready to go face presidents gift
green guy get smudges I'm dying to watch
this tree
let's do it there would be no air nation
without avatar Korra
she opened the portals and somehow the
world began anew for us
and she was even willing to lay down her
own life in order to protect out
one
robots
yeah
Oh
what no I know who she's talking about
that is such a cliffhanger and a good
tea stop for the CIN it's not it's not
funny it's still funny right I'm so
excited you don't even know it's really
[ __ ] cool trailer man that is it's a
really cool trailer do you even know who
Toph is I just established that I did I
should know you don't know who talked
this [ __ ] is wrong with you
snap okay okay do you remember in like
Avatar
the first series with Aang you know
there was the girl who was blind that
Hatem earthbending tough top who is she
I know
holy [ __ ] huh now he realizes oh she has
to be all like really old whoa I got a
question sure what's the show about
cuz that gave no information for me to
be like interesting concept should we
start from the beginning or the chorus
here
I've only eyes but no we should just
give him like the bass thing I want like
a log line okay log like one time
essentially there are four nations earth
fire air and water and the nations all
like 75 80 years ago they were all in
war they'd been in a hundred year war
and then Avatar Aang came forward and
the Avatar can be the master of all four
elements and can control each one and in
each nation there are certain people
like there are airbenders there are well
not anymore
Alyssa there are water benders what up
Alyssa betsa oh is that a sentence just
king I know I know
isn't there a a classic and night
Shyamalan movie based on this oh god no
no no that was a fantastic movie
no best movie I've ever seen hands down
know what happens next
anyway fast forward like 75 80 years
we're with avatar Korra now she's the
next avatar and this is her series and
she's a badass she is like a badass like
within like the first like five minutes
of of the first episode I enjoy watching
female action leans more than I do
male actually you would love this really
well the animation is so [ __ ] good
anyway you can watch the entirety of it
on Nick calm and you should
it's magnificent mm-hmm you should watch
it tonight
mm-hmm I want to watch Avatar The Last
Airbender first then I'll lend you my
box set no I own it on DVD it's a
fantastic go oh good no no no no no the
series why did you why did you think he
was thinking of anything different than
that I don't know I should not have
assumed anyway guys are ready to the
channel have we done good today you
should subscribe to the real rejects
where this guy knows a lot of
information about things that you guys
want to hear me talk about you can
subscribe to Alyssa's channel Elissa be
cray cray cray dance channel that
Storybrooke trample what the hell is
that
did you puke a little in your mouth
sorry Bert yeah I understand you're
doing a robot but also sounded like you
puked a little bit because I was
laughing at my own Joe Irvin Jay dela
Cruz he wants a shout out cool ejd see
that's what they should call you EJ DC
edged it's the second generation of
ac/dc I see you yes you are AJ DC I hope
you have a classic rock band dude
Irvin Jay dela Cruz had one problem with
this comment you didn't give me anything
worth up here am I supposed to make up
something cuz you asked for shoutout
like your names
your name's not even funny your profit
just do it I'm trying to improve it but
I can't come up with anything Alyssa I
felt like we had a lot of good things
going on the name
like what Dan like what like bad ac/dc
jokes yeah yeah yeah that's what's gonna
hook in more subscribers another's van
called a XI D XI and it's me it's a
cover band that does ac/dc and it's all
females really didn't know that I didn't
know that that's pretty cool it's pretty
cool that was worth the shadow yeah
blessing in disguise ah d lack guys
after watching this video before I went
to bed I had a dream where Sally
possessed me with beetles after trying
to drown me whilst also trying to look
inconspicuous about it they're rather
introducing me to the devil I have some
weird dreams give this a shout-out
perhaps sorry Sally I'm guess you
actually don't possess people okay Adi
AK um I would love to give you a
shout-out although I'm kind of worried
that you might be summoning the devil a
little bit the shoutouts the last part
he needs you have to stop now oh [ __ ]
you know based off your thumbnail I know
that's probably not you but you look
like you'd be a Satan worshipper
no wonder the Devils coming after us cuz
of you you know but I have the power of
the Lord and Savior BAM power the Holy
Spirit and kiss that cross boom bada
bing love others the way you want them
to be loved so your devil ways aren't
gonna be coming around me cuz God's
gonna deflect it and there's gonna
hadouken you okay do you read me Faisal
djd hallo
Conroe Texas you make me laugh at 4:00
in the morning shout out please
another night owl o night O Holy Night
good well you get t-shirts DJ Lalo I'm
glad we can make you laugh at 4:00 in
the morning mm-hmm those are weird time
zone hours that you are awake at you
should be 4:00 in the morning I was up
until 8:00 this morning what and then
you texted me back at 5:00 oh yeah so
this is sound like it's benefiting
everyone in your life right now
and DJ Lala texted back yeah okay
DJ Lalo Conroe Texas gets a bed earlier
that's all I'm trying to say actually no
I don't know where you live so if I up
load and it's 4:00 in the morning don't
go to bed
watch the video but after the video
consider sleeping you should at least
consider it you don't have to but as
long as you consider it it's ok stop
drinking coffee you know why I was up so
late last night I was watching the last
half of season 3 of Korra so you know
what it's ok
is it though yes cuz that is the 100 for
centuries I'm not lying in any shape way
shape or form
cuz it's that good and you should watch
it it's that good man you should watch
it you really should no no eat num nums
cheesy no no trying to get sponsorship
from mac and cheese go I can we that
would be I want it on it wait just like
cuz the spirals are delicious with the
regular noodles man those noodles oh I
like the spongebob ones gives us
spongebob yeah that's all I'm using back
you [ __ ] no no Larry you guys can go
to hell
well you parent need the devil is coming
after us
Nona you should hide the devil's now
real we can high-five so hard it scares
them Jesus will protect me for beauty